you see the difference between somebody
who accumulates wealth and somebody who
doesn't is they understand this game the
money game better than you do but here's
the good news
it's a money game and any game you play
a lot you veg to get very good at it it
doesn't matter whether it's Madden
sports or it's poker or monopoly or
anything chess whatever you play a lot
you're going to get very good at it now
this right here is a couple thousand
dollars not a lot of money but it's a
couple thousand dollars here's a here's
one of the bills serial number LDH two
seven zero I think that's a two-for-one
6b okay this hundred dollar bill that
it's in my possession today could have
possibly been in China it's well
traveled maybe was in Brazil maybe was
in Iran maybe was in UK Texas LA New
York Canada I don't know but it's
well-traveled and it's been touched and
in been it's been in position of people
hundreds if not tens of thousands of
people have touched us on the dollar
bill and now one point had control of it
but it's in my hand today this 2,000 is
in my hands today a portion that this is
going to feed my family food a portion
is going to be paid to Uncle Sam taxes
portion is going to go to expenses a
portion is going to go to entertainment
then it's whatever is left if what I do
with what's left that determines how I
accumulate wealth now most people waste
their money a few people just save their
money and even fewer people learn how to
invest it and double their money because
money is a game and the game is a
doubling game that's how many times you
can double this dollars if this is two
thousand can you turn it to four
thousand eight thousand sixteen thousand
32 64 128 256 512 1.2 million million
dollars then 2 million four million
eight million 16 million 32 million
sixty-four million 128 256 512 in a
billion
it is a doubles game and once you learn
how to play this game it becomes so easy
because money is the easiest thing to
make it is so easy to make but it's hard
to keep and even tougher to double and
only those who learn how to double this
money end up accumulating wealth and you
can learn that that's why I created a
video called 20 rules of money that if
you haven't watched yet over half a
million people I think 600
people have already watched if you
haven't watched yet I to go to google
and type and rules of money I think it's
the second one on the bottom you'll see
or go to youtube and type in 20 rules of
money it'll come up even if you just
type toward money on YouTube it'll come
up
go watch the video study the different
concepts start applying them and sooner
or later you'll also learn how to
duplicate and double this money and all
of a sudden someone's going to say man
why do you play this money game so long
because I learned how to play this game
and I can teach you as well
go watch the video message me once you
end up watching the video